Okay, welcome everybody to another somebody saying they can't hear me can you hear me yet. Make sure you turn your speaker on.
No sound.
Oh, some people are saying they can hear me fine so somebody can hear me and somebody can't that it has to be your sound your speaker so please check your speaker turn up your volume on your computer many times that's the problem.
And we will keep rolling and this will be recorded so you can listen to it later if you still can't figure out your volume.
Yes, you can't even hear me if you can't figure out your volume so what am I talking about.
Alright, so let's get going.
Alright, so couple housekeeping things that I say and raise a call make sure you look for questions in our website and our blog.
You can search this little thing on our website.
And then you can search for questions you don't have to wait till the zoom call.
But how you have this wonderful patient membership site.
We've been waiting a long time to finish this and get this done.
Dustin and myself have worked well and hard to do this so hope everybody appreciates it.
That even if you don't appreciate it, hope you use it.
So this is where you need to submit your questions so if you have not been on the patient membership site.
Search your email for search your email the email that yours your made email that you used to start with us that was on your intake form that you gave us as your made email.
Search for either info at cutters clinic.com because that's where you're welcome letter your email should have come from last Thursday we launched this so last Thursday.
At noon this site was launched and every one of you should have gotten an email from info cutters clinic.com saying welcome to cutters clinic patient membership site.
And this is how you log in to you log in via that email that you gave us and then you create your own password.
So if you haven't done that, please do that you can also search for membership and look for cutters clinic.
Because you should see it there so we do still have been receiving some questions via an email to cutters clinic or my email.
So if you happen anymore your questions should come through our patient membership site.
There is a form at the bottom of nearly every page where submit your zoom call questions and on the zoom call question page.
See right here zoom calls will take on that so there's multiple pages in this site it is literally a brand new website and it's got things on there that are only available to our patients.
I spent a lot of time putting the information together a lot of your questions that you ask may already be answered on a short little video on that site.
So look for that that's where all these zoom call recordings will be placed as well you could see last week zoom call on this site.
So there will always be uploaded and put out here for future use.
So if you can't find that and go to this if you search for this and you still don't see an invite and email athletics and I don't I can't find my invite and we can resend it to you.
So please look for that.
Alright let's get to your questions.
I'm on a medication and do I need to take the medicine several hours away from the right doesn't make a difference what medication it is.
Do you can you not take your medication while you're using the right the answer is no that makes no difference whatsoever.
Well there's a question maybe they're thinking should I not do the eye on pro wave right after I take my medication will it pull the medication out of my body if you don't evidence that either so you don't have to worry about timing with right for use we don't have to worry about timing with a pro wave use as far as use of any medication there should be no interference with that.
How often do I need to do coffee enemies well that depends on you you should ask your liaison that person I don't ask this question.
So typically we recommend coffee enemies daily some people can't do them daily because they have rectal cancer they can't do them at all so everybody's a little bit unique with that personally I don't do coffee enemies at all.
I should say that because I did one last couple weeks ago, but it's but I don't do them regularly anymore so
that's just for me that's myself and tidy and busyness of life so I don't do that on a regular basis but it doesn't lead you can't do that on a regular basis.
So if a person's in a lot of pain they have a lot of inflammation or they have any edema build up in their gut or their lungs that it's typically recommended that you do more than one coffee enemy day we've had people do five coffee enemies a day
So what's the purpose of that I'm not constipated go back to understand what the purpose of a coffee enemy is.
The purpose of the coffee enemy is to stimulate your parasympathetics and by stimulating the parasympathetics you you help walk pain pathways as well so by doing coffee enemies you can help mitigate pain.
And again you could do a very simplified version of a coffee enemy oh there's no way I can lay down on my side and do a coffee enemy the way it's recommended I can it's hard for me to get up that causes more pain.
You could go do a coffee enemy standing in the shower hold it for two three minutes and then go void that's still going to stimulate your parasympathetics so you can get created with these things so
I talked to some of the other day that hold making the coffee in the pot the way it's recommended on your videos is that's just oh my gosh it's just hard for me I live alone.
So put a sakes get some organic coffee, brew it in your coffee maker and then cool it with water and use that do any form of coffee animal like this is going to be beneficial it doesn't have to be don't get hung up on what's perfect
and then not do it because of that reason I'm wondering if Dr. Cutters is able to send orders for blood transfusion no we can't do that so we can't send orders for blood transfusion we can't send orders for a CT scan or an MRI or even an ultrasound you're going to have to get that from a primary position.
I'm thankful for more energy and stamina and following my protocol to see the results bladder cancer is hard to status but today I feel well and I know the age of the Lord and camps around me Amen.
God is using the story he has given me in cancer to speak his good will still pray for you Dr. Cutters thank you.
The joy of the Lord is restored to praise God well God is good all always even if we're not doing better even if I'm getting sicker even if I might pass away from this cancer it doesn't change the goodness and the greatness of God in my life I trust in his sovereignty in all things and go and praise God for that.
I'm trying to be proactive with having on the back's friends with my blood type to donate blood for me in case I need a transfusion idea there's a lot of vaccinated people on here try to insult you and I know this person has no idea that they're not trying to insult anybody either.
But the vaccine itself and we're talking about the pool and vaccine has factors in it that I personally would want to put into my veins.
So I contacted Memorial Blood Bank today this can be done so this is good information so I put it up here takes about seven business days for the time of donation to be available to me first step.
I need ordering doctor to fill out this form and this page so you can utilize this form if you need to receive blood and you want people to donate blood for you so that can be stored for you.
Great information thank you to the person who submitted this this can be beneficial to a lot of people.
Next question some natural path doctor more for one suggests that the kidney should be filtering so urine appears cloudy or has particulates in it that this is an indication that the lib kidney readers are working correctly I understand that if you're not showing sentiment in your urine you are not getting rid of acidic waste.
And your live system is not working optimally that I really don't understand this process or whether the kiddie is filtering is truly necessary could you please talk about this subject.
Yeah, so I would not agree with this comment whatsoever when you do a UA your analysis that's one of the things that the test trick is looking for is sediment or cloudy urine that's a sign of possible infection and some other things.
So it certainly is not a sign of acidic waste better better a fact typically cloudy or sediment in your urine is going to be calcium particulates which is going to cause the year to be more alkaline not acidic so I'm not sure where this is coming from for physiological standpoint.
Your kidneys are an essential part of your detoxification process of major organ of detoxification with your liver, your ball bladder, your large intestine and your skin so it is necessary for them to be working, but I wouldn't be concerned about whether they're sediment in my urine or not.
Like to be wrong, I'm just telling you my opinion, with colon cancer following my cutters, clinic protocol, how do we determine progress as we made that is what testing it is there a suggested interval months to three months, et cetera, certainly there is the option of CT scans MRIs and maybe even a scope.
Inspection of the colon but what do what do clients do to arrange those do they unless they're a collegeist hasn't asked my colleges to do those things especially that participating in their recommended therapy good question so this is a video that I actually created on our membership site so on our membership site you go to that you can look at how do I know I'm getting better video and you can read.
So watch that video and help understand that but in short yes the best way to know whether your cancer is improving or not is to compare apples to apples if you have a CT scan that measures a tumor of 4.5 centimeters round that another CT scan best done by that same hospital or clinic.
Measuring that comparative study would be the best way to compare whether my cancer is getting better or not but most of my patients go want to keep doing CT scans great allowed that's a lot of radiation i don't want to keep doing that is there another way to test well that's where you go to that video and the membership site.
You can use tumor markers some cancer still show to the workers what am I supposed to do what we used to have the tomorrow test well that is being backed up and some.
People have said that they're not even accepting tests right now because cancer is literally going like wildfire around the world and they are backed up and they can't even accept any more tests we used to have the ivy gene but during covid they ended up getting they ended up closing because they didn't have enough business.
So it is difficult to know how to measure progress sometimes this is why I tell people it's best not to burn your bridges with your oncologist just kindly say can I get back to you when I want to start something I just don't want to start something right now would you help me with testing as I try to do some things on my own if they say no it's my way or the highway.
To find another oncologist they're they're all over the place go to somebody else and say hey you know this guy just booted me because I wouldn't do his protocol i'm trying to pray about my situation and make a decision as best for me I just want somebody to monitor it nine times at a time you're going to find the next person go oh we'll take care of you we're not on my way or the highway place we want to just support you and serve you thinking.
thinking you know that they that's really their desire or thinking that hey if they use us out of the road that is great so that's my suggestion so yes there is no.
You know magic bullets out there of testing that you can measure progress with here we are we there's this limited technology that exists today unfortunately hopefully at some time the future that will change.
But the tomorrow test on standby and no options for IVG test built by CTA that's the markers are in normal rage not sure of a cancer marker test worth doing so yeah it becomes difficult like I said there are you can do the CA 125 possibly with with colon cancer.
I mean it had some colon cancer show up at 2729 but that's more rare you can look at other markers to other inflammatory markers possibly but yeah it was nothing that's going to be perfect and quite honestly even the gold standard CT scans is then perfect so.
You can get false positive gross and false positive shrinkages usually not that but usually false positive gross called pseudo pseudo gross that are not beneficial at all to see so.
yeah that's something that is just difficult to deal with trust me I don't want yet another supplement but I'm curious about the iron I'm taking for anemia.
Since cancer likes tired and wondering about artimistic in my particular case so yeah typically what a person is taking iron we recommend taking artimistic in with it.
But artimistic it has been found to follow higher and artimistic in can be a cancer killer especially the inside of a cancer cell.
But so can some other things too so don't sell that sure maybe it's best just to take your iron with your other supplements so that it can follow other things can take along with there's just that research on everything else when we just don't know what could possibly take what could possibly happen.
So maybe try taking it just with your other supplements and not add artimistic this point in time certainly you can but again I would favor of less this more.
What's the difference with Ivermectin and fed bed is all tested well for fed bed is all does that mean Ivermectin would be good to take with it or in replacement of it or should I just stop taking Ivermectin and just take the iron.
fed bed is all I'd say the last thing we should just stop taking the Ivermectin unless you feel like that is helping too but they're totally different drugs so they're they're they're very different so you can't switch about so they're it's not a flip flop they can both be helpful their studies on the Ivermectin with cancer.
But before they thought anybody use it but but they're not interchangeable I recently got an old test that's an organic acid test results for Evan if he has high oxalates we are reducing them it is diet giving magnesium citrate so magnesium citrate can help to oxalates in the gut.
Red easy citrate is really good if you're constipated too so and using Epsom salt baths I will add calcium citrate because calcium citrate can buy oxalates in the gut as well.
When I have his constipation under control I wanted to check to see if bad it's our brain anti-inflammatory mix or too narrow clear would be high in oxalates I'd say no so continue to take those.
I got a hair analysis back for doctors data and using anti-cutlers counting rules and he covers really an expert he was really an expert in heavy metal detox and such not as essential elements he meets one rule there is low mercury in the toxic elements but in my experience that is only from fish and he only eats salmon on occasion.
It isn't the worst hair test I've ever seen but it indicates some mercury toxicity is it's dangerous to dress at this point will it that be necessary at some point.
So the real question is when you're dealing with cancer and you have a toxicity that you know you have we dealt with this with dental issues I know I have
a toxic teeth that I want to deal with are mercury and my mercury fillings that I want to get out should I get those out right now I say slow down wait until we get things balanced out and then we can deal with purposefully deep fully you know mercury out of your teeth through a through a biological dentist.
You don't want to spill too many toxins and you could do that if you're using key laders strong key laders.
You don't want to do that especially when you're dealing with cancer because that could cause a bit of laboratory reaction especially with brain cancer so I would say wait on those things remember to go back to the website and download the seven phases of detoxification because that will explain to you that.
You might do a specific key lation for a heavy metal or something like that or if you're going to have the mercury out of your teeth but detoxification is a process that you're doing constantly and you're supporting those pathways constantly.
It is what I call phase zero of the detoxification phases the seven phases where you are actually trying to use a product to key later your grabbing onto something in the tissue pointed out of the body you want to make sure you're supporting all those other phases before you're doing that and before you get to aggressive doing that at least.
And that you've called out any other inflammation in the body and you feel like you're healthier and healthier state to be able to do that so we don't want to hold on to this.
Last reminder is please mail your cheek swabs to this address it is on the what it's membership site to so other membership site you have the cheek swab download and where you can order cheek swabs from our website and it has that address there to so if you arrived at this call late on the zoom call.
Make sure that you get on our membership site that again if all I get out your membership site I don't know I confused I don't remember anything about a membership site search for through your main email search for informed colors clinic.com or search membership in your main email and you should see an invite follow that invite the directions create.
Use your user name of the email that's going to be your early choice create a password and get on our membership site where you can see lots of pages new pages and only members can see a lot of questions answered and you can get the zoom calls that are recorded and downloaded into to that site.
Remember to email your cheek swabs back to there again.
Okay let's jump to some questions that you've said there's one comment I have been making my coffee for my coffee in a while concentrate four days worth at a time after that I refrigerate and then I do back to normal to use daily do you see any problem with that no that's a great way to do it.
But there are some people that are very ill and that feeling you know that feeling well and they just want to do a coffee and then I didn't make it a coffee that's where I was talking about earlier about.
But it's just brew a cup of coffee and use that so try to keep it simple make it easy so that you could do it so you don't feel like you have to follow all these rules in order to get good results can a drop of frankincense increase white blood cells.
I don't know, I've never seen any data on that.
Should we not take any supplements two hours before and after rife no no you should be taking no again the rife isn't going to repeat on your supplements on your medication.
You take your supplements while you're doing the rife you can eat dinner while you're doing the rife you can play chess while you do the rife you can do an Irish jig while you're doing the rife.
If you can please send a video on that though because we'd like to get that up on the membership site that would be wonderful.
Suggestions for help with hot flashes with ERPR negative and her to positive breast cancer.
So hot flashes have to do with fluctuation of estrogen and the first step that I would go to a hot flashes with breast cancer even if you're ERPR negative and her to negative I would still go to adaptogens.
So remember that the majority of your estrogen is created by your ovaries but your adredals also create some estrogen to that's why you you know when you go through menopause or if you have a hysterectomy you still have estrogen.
Well, where's that coming from coming from your adrenal glands so if you're having fluctuations of estrogen causing hot flashes then what you want to do is start with supporting adredals so there's adaptogens that I'd recommend ask your.
You're already on adaptogens and then ask your liaison because it might not be that adaptogens using maca we use a product called astral right with some people, but I want to make sure we test it on you.
Because it does have soy price of labels in it which which can affect estrogen levels for people that are HR her to positive doesn't that ways of a test okay that it's okay to use what we should test that.
Should I discontinue supplements that require food when using the prologue.
No, no, I would just take it with with your meal with prologue so when you're doing your soup with the FMD so if you don't know what prologue FMD it's a it's a fasting mimicky diet product that gives you five days of food but it's not much food so it keeps you under a calorie content that you are.
It mimics fasting in your body without increasing IGF one levels so it's ideal for cancer patients because if you do a long term fast as a cancer patient the negative is is that you will raise IGF one levels now that's not bad if you don't have cancer but if you have cancer that can not be a good thing so.
If you're going to do a fast more than 24 hours we recommend doing what's called fasting mimicky diet company that makes that is company called prologue the researcher is forgot his name but he's out of university of Southern California school that I said brilliant guy heard him speak a couple times.
I've done the prologue FMD multiple times my staff has done a multiple times we've had different patients do it it can be really good you do not want to even consider this if you're kind of at your perfect weight or a little below because you will probably lose weight on this but if they I could you know would hurt me to lose a little weight and I really want to clean myself out to do a fast that FMD is a great choice.
Great for a person who doesn't have cancer also especially for pre diabetic patients that want to really help control blood sugar and people that have oxidized LDLs with heart issues great product for fasting and you feel like you're pretty hungry but it's not a five day fast.
It's like a full water fast you could certainly take your supplements at the time that you eat your soup meals they're all dehydrated for soup meals for your olives olives delicious for your teeny little bar so yeah so hopefully everybody has gotten on the patient membership site we received several of these questions that came in and we talked about from people that jumped on that site and
we used that for them said to their questions said that was great so I remember to do that and we have to get your questions answered as best as possible and you'll be able to see all those in calls out there any other questions
tonight or what can you explain how IDF1 goes up when fasting no that's above my pay grade just dance for about 24 hours of fasting your IDF1 levels go all right well thank you guys all for being on here also on the patient membership site if you guys have ideas
for short little videos for me to create please you know add it as a question I might add it to our question in the zoom call but I'm going to be created some other short video so that you don't have to be waiting for the zoom call for your questions to be answered
we want this zoom call for your questions to be answered but we rather have you have your questions answered before waiting for five days for the zoom call we would like this to be more of a support group so we're always here for you so please utilize that site and give us ideas for improvement in that as well so and again for all of you know that I'm praying for you daily
and cherish your prayers for us as well well thank you guys and we will see you next week bye bye